Speaker 1: if you want to call into the show,
but you want to leave me a message as opposed
to talk to me live.
You can call literally any time of day three
a.m., as many people call in two p.m. whenever
you can call two one nine two David P. and
you can leave a voicemail.
Here's a voicemail about it.
I guess we would call them inter political
relationships, relationships between left
and right wingers.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, quick question.
Speaker 1: Do you think you could date or
marry a good faith conservative nominee to
hit on people,
Speaker 2: do you think?
Because I know Bill Maher talked about this
on his show one time about I can't think of
a couple, but one of them was a Republican
strategist and the husband was a liberal strategist,
Democratic strategist.
But from what I understand, they were both
reasonable people.
They weren't you know, one of them wasn't
crazy, right wing lunatic or crazy left wing.
Do you think you could do a pretty much middle
of the road, reasonable, intelligent, conservative
or or.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, listen, this is a this is a good question.
I once did date a conservative sort of, but
at the time I didn't know she was a conservative
at the time.
She really wasn't a conservative.
Her family was in politics, just weren't on
my radar.
I think had that relationship lasted, it would
not have worked because it was pretty wacky
brand of conservatism.
But but beyond that, you know, as an adult,
it's hard to imagine.
I mean, listen, I think if you want to come
up with a sort of conservative who, like,
thinks taxes should be lower than I think
they should be and doesn't think Medicare
for all is the right way to arrange health
care and can sort of like reasonably defend
it.
But they're not homophobic or anti-abortion.
I mean, I think that a lot of the social issues
would be tougher because in a in a social
context, that starts to become weird and awkward.
And I would also question a lot of the social
things, like you can think taxes should be
lower than I think they should be, but more
or less have a moral framework that is in
line with mine.
It's hard for me to imagine someone who's
homophobic, anti-abortion, extremely religious,
and, you know, thinks creationism should be
taught in science class who otherwise is going
to share my values in a way that wouldn't
be a.
Problem, so I guess what I'm saying is if
the differences are economic to some degree
or something like that, it seems like that
would not be a problem relationship wise.
But but going beyond that, I think would be
extremely difficult.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Manhattan will stop prosecuting prostitution
and will dismiss cases dating back decades.
Very interesting decision made there.
A governor, Kay Ivey of Alabama, has signed
a bill allowing college athletes to monetize
their name, image and likeness.
Very interesting in terms of what it will
do in a number of different ways for athletes
in Alabama.
And Joe Biden, as I mentioned earlier, is
calling for every employee to get paid leave
for vaccinations and in fact, putting in place
a tax credit for employers to allow employees
to get paid to be paid.
That paid leave, I think better said to go
and get vaccinated.
Will this move the needle?
We'll talk about that and more on the bonus
show.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
Two ways.
No.
One, become a member at join Pakman Dotcom.
Easy, quick.
You'll be listening or watching, listening
to or watching the bonus show in under a minute.
Second option.
Patreon become a patron at Patreon Dotcom
Slash
Unidentified: David Pakman show.
I will see you that.